-
Nationale n'a pas d'autre choix.
Il faut  recruter
à l'international pour avoir
du personnel en CHSLD.
Originaitie des 46 préposés aux
bénéficiaires qui sont arrivés
à Québec au cours de l'été.
NAJWA ESSID, prép. aux bénéf.
CIUSSS de la Capitale-Nationale
le Québec pour un nouveau défi
professionnel, pour améliorer
la vie, même la vie
de ma famille, qui sont enco
- Tous les employés recrutés
à l'international doivent
d'abord venir ici sans
leur famille. C'estation. Datat,
Najwa exerçait la profession
d'infirmière. Elle est
maintenant préposée
d'hébergement Jeffrey Hale.
- J'aime beaucoup ce travail
de préposée aux bénéficiaires
humanitaire. Je l'aime beaucoup,
j'aime les personnes âgées.
- Pour que les employés
leur travail, mais également
leur nouvelle vie, le CIUSSS
met tout en place.ie et son équ,
c'est un'intégration
assez ardu.LAVOIE, chLAVOIE, chs
aux ressources humaines
- On les prépare beaucouple pro.
s rentre pas comme ça
non plus sur les unités.
chercher les candidatsà l'aérop,
pour ensuite les emmener
Laval, où ils sont hébergésau ms
aident aussi les nouveaux
les meilleures épiceries,
les magasins, se créer un compte
bancaire et se loger.
un pays nouveau, ils ne sont pas
portés à poser des questions.
Donc, c'est vraiment de créer
ce soit avec nous, l'équipe
qu'on a construiteuter
à l'international, que ce soit
avec les gestionnaires
utilisé un préposé aux
bénéficiest passé par
là, qui est un genre de mentor
pour répondre à leurs questions.
- J'aime beaucoup mes collègues,
vraiment, ils sont, ils sont, is
avec moi.
- Maintenant, Najwqu'un souhait.
- Juste que mes de
et mon mari viennent
le plus vite possi
- Le CIUSSS de la Capitale-
National dans ses
démarches, qui pourraient
prendre